good evening everyone I'm Laura Ingram
this is the Ingram angle from Washington
tonight an elderly man with a poor
memory and one who willfully retained
and disclosed classified documents that
is how special counsel Robert herd
described the current president of the
United States in his report on the Biden
classified documents investigation now
while her ultimately decided not to
charge Biden for mishandling the
classified documents going back decades
the bigger news was what his team
uncovered about the president's mental
faculties or lack thereof the 345 page
document is the mustre tell all of the
day complete with gems like this he the
president did not remember when he was
vice president forgetting on the first
day of the interview when his term ended
if it was uh 2013 when did I stop being
vice president and forgetting on the
second day of the interview when his
term began in 20 9 as still vice
president he did not remember even
within several years when his son Bo
died and his memory appeared hazy when
describing the Afghanistan debate that
was once so important to
him now there is simply no way to
explain this you know the White House is
worried about the report when Biden's
attorneys felt the need to dispute the
findings about the president's
terrifying memor cpses writing we do not
believe that the report's treatment of
Biden's memory is accurate or
appropriate the report uses highly
prejudicial language to describe a
commonplace occurrence among Witnesses a
lack of recall of years old events wait
wait wait wait wait wait okay these are
two white collar criminal attorneys
right they alleged the reports treatment
of Biden's memory isn't accurate or
appropriate now are they accusing Mr her
of fabricating the fact that Biden
couldn't recall even the general time
frame of when his son
died or or they implying uh that
President Biden was lying and really did
remember those
things how is it highly prejudicial to
quote the president's own answers
verbatim must be mag's fault now hers
team went into detail about the
president's debilitated memory not to be
cruel and not forl iCal reasons but
because it's relevant to whether they
could have established intent writing in
the report in a case where the
government must prove that Mr Biden knew
he had possession of the classified
Afghanistan documents after the vice
presidency and chose to keep those
documents knowing he was violating the
law we expect that at trial his
attorneys would emphasize these
limitations in his Recall now marinate
on that for a moment what her revealed
in this report is what we've been
telling you for years the Democrat Party
the media the party's plutocrat donors
who've all been behind closed doors with
Biden the
entire Biden presidency has been a lie
because they've known the truth from day
one all of those groups he's obviously
not capable he's obviously not in charge
he has no concept of time and space and
that's
dangerous and on top of that he's turned
America into a laughing
stock The Babylon be in tragic comedic
fashion captured the moment
perfectly man ruled too scile to stand
trial still fine to run country hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else